la chroniqueuse sport comme tous les
lundis bonsoir Anthony bonsoir Wilfried
on va s'intéresser au raid Amazon arbre
vert les aventurières sont revenus il y
en a deux qui sont en plateau avec nous
Emilie beau bonsoir à vous et Sabrina
quiz toutes les deux vous revenez de ce
aventure c'est à l'île Maurice vous
allez nous dire comment ça s'est passé
vous avez pris des couleurs en tout cas
déjà la barre c'était plutôt sympathique
après revenir ici dans la grisaille ça a
dû être difficile et pour l'instant
Anthony on va parler extra sportif on va
pas s'intéresser au sport à proprement
parler oui on va tout d'abord parler de
sponsoring puisque dans le sport de haut
niveau évidemment c'est synonyme de
budget important sans les mécènes les
clubs ne peuvent pas vivre en tout
simplement ou même survivre et l'Étoile
sportive des cheminées au trappes le
club de basket de Trappes connaît depuis
quelques saisons des difficultés
justement au niveau partenaire au niveau
budget alors qu'ils sont en National 2
une très bonne division nationale depuis
plusieurs années ce week-end à
l'occasion d'un match de championnat
face à Calais deux partenaires
importants historiques de l'ESCT
renouveler leur confiance au club images
de Guillaume camps
300000 euros c'est le montant du budget
trappiste en basket cette saison soit
l'un des plus petits de National 2 quand
la moyenne tourne autour de 400 000
euros sur la communauté d'agglomération
de 50 ans en Yvelines trouver des
sponsors s'avère compliqué c'est bien
évidemment pas suffisant si on quand on
a des ambitions il faut maintenant tout
ne se fait pas qu'avec l'argent mais là
on est vraiment pour le coup un petit
peu limité il manque quelques quelques
partenaires qui nous permettraient aussi
de pérenniser pérenniser la vie du club
et puis d'avoir des objectifs ambitieux
parce que on doit avoir des objectifs
sur trap et 50 ans en Yvelines avant la
rencontre de championnats deux
partenaires historiques du club
renouvelé leur confiance à le SCT la
société see Simoni a prolongé son
partenariat pour la dixième année et il
préva fête ses 11 années de mariage
présentation Nationale 2 depuis 5
saisons le club vise la montée en
National Lune à l'horizon 2014 voir en
Pro B en 2016 mais pour cela il faudra
trouver 200000 euros de nouveaux
partenariats sont à l'étude en attendant
le club doit faire avec les moyens du
bord et s'est offert pour l'occasion la
présence d'un ministre c'est la crise
n'ont pas non plus des marges telles
qu'elles peuvent distribuer ainsi et
d'échecs d'où l'importance du projet et
que les entreprises soient convaincus
que derrière le projet il y a aussi en
associant le nom de leur marque à cette
à ce club la possibilité de renforcer
leur propre attractivité mais aussi
l'attractivité du territoire ce projet
le SCT est en train de le construire le
club trappiste s'oriente sur la
formation en s'ouvrant aux autres villes
de la communauté d'agglomération comme
la verrière ou Montigny-le-Bretonneux et
quoi de mieux pour lancer ces signatures
qu'une victoire sur son parquet face à
Calais 64 à 63
effectivement le SCT a regroupé à la
victoire ce week-end face à Calais 1 64
à 63 comme je le disais dans le sujet
mais c'est seulement le troisième succès
de la saison pour les joueurs de Mustafa
et la fady qui reste lanterne rouge de
National 2 mais avec seulement un point
de retard maintenant sur le premier
non-regable Maubeuge que le SCT
d'ailleurs ce weekend samedi soir dans
un match qui s'annonce pour le moins
tendu Wilfrid un peu de soleil à présent
le raid Amazon alors oui laurier on va
voyager on va aller direction l'île
Maurice avec nous sur ce plateau Émilie
beau et Sabrina Kies bonsoir à vous deux
première question est-ce que vous avez
le Red blues un petit peu
quand on revient d'une telle aventure on
a passé 10 jours 24 heures sur 24 avec
ses copines et puis on a été choyé par
toute l'organisation donc revenir là on
se prend déjà 30 degrés dans la figure
donc ça c'est difficile et puis après la
vie qui reprend son cours en normal
c'est bien mais on s'est habitué un
petit peu à penser qu'à nous
Sabrina justement vous êtes revenu en un
seul morceau pas de blessure pour vous
c'était votre premier aide la découverte
comment ça s'est passé et bien on a
réussi les deux missions quand c'était
fixées donc ça c'est génial donc déjà on
s'est pas blessé on a réussi à porter
tous les jeux qu'on voulait là-bas donc
on a apporté les 30 kg de jouets à
l'association Caritas
solidaire avait aussi cet aspect
humanitaire où vous ameniez des jeux
pour les pour les enfants de l'île
Maurice les centres de loisirs c'est ça
parce que là-bas c'est les vacances
scolaires en ce moment les grandes
vacances et donc on pouvait importer 10
kg il y a 20 kg qui enfin qu'on avait
sur les bras les les filles à l'aéroport
ont été géniales parce que on a fait
notre distribution et chacune a pris un
jeu ou deux pour les emmener là-bas et
donc voilà les 30 kg de jouets sont
arrivés à bon port et puis ensuite voilà
on s'est pas blessé on s'est surpassé à
notre niveau et voilà c'est vraiment une
aventure extraordinaire en plus pour
votre premier aide un résultat plutôt
correct vous finissez 20e sur 80 équipes
c'est plutôt plutôt satisfaisant
inespéré même franchement l'objectif
c'était quoi pour vous c'était d'y aller
de se surpasser mais à notre niveau bon
voilà on a un niveau vous étiez pas
voilà on s'était pas mis de pression on
voulait pas
enfin on voulait tout donner mais on
savait qu'on avait pas un niveau
exceptionnel et on a formé un trio qui a
fonctionné à merveille assez génial
voilà on a une troisième qui nous a
poussé qui nous a boosté qui nous a
donné des ailes et voilà c'est c'était
génial donc vous y retourner l'année
prochaine et vous finissez dans le top 3
le top 3 il est déjà occupé puisque
l'équipe de d'Émilie les poissons rouges
bah vous avez terminé deuxième tout
simplement c'était inattendu aussi
puisque nous on y allait alors un petit
peu comme Sabrina aussi pas pour faire
une performance mais pour se faire
plaisir l'objectif c'était de prendre le
départ à trois de toutes les épreuves et
tous les jours suite une mauvaise
expérience de l'année dernière où on
avait une coéquipière qui s'était
gravement blessée et donc on voulait lui
prouver que l'expérience était
l'expérience sportive était de nouveau
possible remonter à cheval un petit peu
entre guillemets à cheval exactement
on a mis très longtemps à se décider
parce que
parce que ce remède d'une telle blessure
c'est compliqué puisqu'elle est tombée
dans le coma suite à une déshydratation
assez sévère et donc
il a fallu du temps de l'entraînement de
nouveau de la confiance en soi et puis
en fait c'est nos sponsors des autres
années qui nous ont un petit peu motivé
qui ont dit allez les filles faut
repartir
ils ont eu raison au final et alors les
profs la plus difficile qu'elle était le
c'était quoi c'était le canoë c'était le
vélo le trek peut-être pour moi c'était
le vélo parce que j'ai trouvé que
l'épreuve était très technique c'est il
y avait énormément de dénivelé je sais
plus combien il y avait de mètres mais
des descentes avec un coup de cailloux
démonter également où on a enfin moi en
tout cas j'ai beaucoup été à côté du
vélo en plus nous on a cassé un
dérailleur donc on n'a pas eu de chance
le mécanicien n'a pas pu réparer donc on
a fini en roue libre on a cru que on
allait abandonner et en fait mon
Caroline nous a dit on sait jamais
terminé les filles tant qu'on est debout
on y va et tout et bon finalement on a
on a terminé l'épreuve mais nous on en a
vraiment bavé ce jour-là et pour vous
Émilie en plus c'était pas votre
première aide donc vous aviez un peu
l'expérience j'imagine ah oui bah je
confirme quand même le vélo il était
très technique
puis c'est le cannique donc un terrain
très accidenté pas du tout de sentier de
scientifiques tracés donc que de la lave
la roche volcanique là et puis et du
dénivelé je crois que on était pas loin
des 750 mètres de dénivelé donc ça
montait bien ça descendait bien en fait
tout était technique il y a quasiment
pas de plat donc sur l'épreuve de vélo
et en course à pied c'est pareil en fait
c'est pas une promenade de santé vous
êtes de deux équipes différentes est-ce
qu'il y a des échanges entre les équipes
où est-ce qu'il y a une vraie
concurrence parce que là vous êtes côte
à côte tout se passe bien est-ce que sur
le terrain c'est pareil en fait elle se
battait
sur cette épreuve
enfin moi j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait une
entraide entre les filles bon c'est vrai
que les trois premières équipes vous
êtes loin devant quand même mais nous le
reste on va dire un peu moins forte on
voilà si on a une qui a arrêté sur le
bord de la route ben on va s'arrêter on
va lui demander si on a besoin d'aide
non par contre là j'en veux un peu
bon là c'était hier
mais non non il y a une entrée
franchement il y a des filles même on a
envoyé le soir parce que les filles se
remercient entre elles il y a des filles
elles lâche tout elles vont chercher les
filles donc le chrono là elles en ont
plus rien à faire donc voilà c'est un
côté vraiment humain et c'est ça qui est
formidable sur ce côté humain ça ça a
renforcé la cohésion de vos équipes
respectives vous êtes ressorti là encore
plus soudée entre vous trois dans chaque
dans chaque équipe pour ma part oui
parce que c'est déjà en plus on était un
petit peu en communion avec une autre
équipe qui finit 3e et avec laquelle on
s'est on va dire tirer la bourre très
très le sentiment sur sur chaque épreuve
on avait un petit jeu
pour voir si c'était derrière mais ça
c'était des petites blagues entre nous
on chambray et puis ce qui était drôle
c'est que sur chaque épreuve il y en
avait toujours une équipe qui a été
devant l'autre etc et le dernier jour on
est arrivé main dans la main on a
franchi la ligne d'arriver ensemble pour
le dernier trek qui était très difficile
et où certaines équipes se sont perdus
d'ailleurs à l'arrivée enfin un
kilomètre à mon arrivée et donc c'était
non non c'est c'est des beaux souvenirs
quoi Émilie vous qui avez fait le le
raid en Guyane l'année dernière en 2011
celui-ci à l'île Maurice était plus
compliqué plus difficile plus difficile
parce que plus technique et beaucoup
plus de dénivelé alors que en Guyane
tout le relief était plat
la seule chose en Guyane c'était le
l'humidité la température alors là
fallait vraiment faire face et ça ça
c'était difficile mais sinon les
distances étaient plus courtes également
à cause de ces conditions climatiques et
alors vous êtes prêtes toutes les deux à
repartir pour un tour ou pas du tout
Sabrina quand j'envoie les images oui
vous allez nous dire oui parce que c'est
quand même plutôt plutôt magnifique moi
je me rappelle de la dernière épreuve où
je m'étais dit plus jamais tellement
j'en ai bavé et en fait deux jours après
en regardant les photos après avoir
passé la dernière journée à l'hôtel à la
piscine et tout voilà c'est ça c'est
incroyable on oublie il y a vraiment que
le meilleur qui reste et je crois que je
serai partante pour repartir dans les
mêmes conditions parce que notre équipe
a tellement bien fonctionné voilà que
ça peut que se passer bien et donc je
dirais oui et vous Émilie après avoir eu
cette deuxième place il y a pas envie
d'aller chercher un petit peu plus haut
de conquérir le sacre sur le reste de
l'arbre vert très honnêtement très
honnêtement j'ai je sais que la première
place elle est inaccessible parce que
les premières elles sont vraiment
plus de 30 minutes devant nous et c'est
pas du tout un hasard donc voilà nous
cette deuxième place elle est c'est le
résultat c'est sûr d'un entraînement de
longue haleine mais c'est aussi enfin
parce qu'il y a toujours une part et ça
j'en suis persuadé de hasard dans
n'importe quel dans n'importe quelle
compétition sportive non plus les
performances
et que personne est à l'abri d'un
accident ou même de d'avoir peut-être
une mauvaise entente dans son équipe ou
voilà des mauvaises conditions
climatiques
une défaillance technique voilà après
moi ça fait trois fois que je le fais
j'ai vraiment j'adore je pense que oui
dans l'idée j'ai envie de leur faire
c'est sûr mais que déjà trois fois c'est
bien
par contre vous allez partir donc on
vous retrouvera sur le plateau l'année
prochaine voilà
c'est de la bonne nouvelle vidéo
merci beaucoup à toutes les deux d'être
venu sur le plateau de téléfils et puis
bah on suivra Sabrina si vous participez
à nouveau et puis bonne chance à vous
Emilie pour les prochaines compétitions
et merci Anthony on poursuit cette page
de sport du lundi 7 chronique de sport
avec du tir à l'arc oui du tir à l'arc
c'était la répétition générale pour les
archers de Guyancourt ce week-end le
club de tir à l'arc organisait son
traditionnel concours annuel
qualificatif pour les championnats
régionaux et nationaux l'occasion de
s'attarder un petit peu sur ce sport
toujours aussi élégant ou la force
mentale est prépondérante l'image de
Guillaume camps
le jaune doit être probablement la
couleur la plus présente dans la tête
d'un archet toucher ce fameux centre de
la cible doit provoquer de nombreux
moments de doute dans une carrière
membre de l'équipe de France au début
des années 2000 l'expérience de Sandrine
Varlet lui permet d'appréhender le pas
de tir plus sereinement dans un sport où
l'aspect mental est primordial faut
rester bien concentré c'est vrai que ça
dure à peu près trois heures la
compétition il faut savoir rester
concentré au moment et être régulier
dans sa concentration et dans son tir
mais sinon oui le stress monte plus avec
les leur des matchs quoi lors des duels
éliminatoires la tension de l'arc peut
créer quelques tremblements il faut donc
avoir une confiance en soi inébranlable
pour tirer la flèche au bon moment sans
être obsédé par le mille la mécanique
doit être parfaitement huilée de façon à
ce que le lâcher de flèche devienne
quasiment artistiques si on pense au
centre de la cible on le fait pour
voilà il faut absolument être disons
avoir une technique qui est d'une
technique une bonne technique de façon à
pouvoir lâcher sa flèche correctement
j'oriente mon arc vers la cible et une
fois que c'est en cible je n'y pense
plus je tiens je cherche à tracter
uniquement la flèche mais si on pense
aux jeunes c'est si on fait point jaune
260 archers étaient présents sur le pas
de tir ce week-end les archers de
Guyancourt se sont illustrés avec une
médaille d'or en vétéran le club 50 noir
organisera le championnat régional en
salle en février prochain
un sujet à présent qui va forcément vous
intéresser même si vous ne faites pas de
sport juste pour voir Anthony en bavé
lors d'un entraînement je suis en un
seul morceau Wilfried c'est déjà c'est
déjà rassurant vous c'était difficile ce
matin au bureau où je traînais un petit
peu la jambe il faut l'avouer tout à
fait oui donc ce weekend il y avait les
championnats régionaux de taekwondo ou 4
athlètes du TKD 78 ce sont qualifiés
pour les championnats de France dont
Mathias et cannelle mais 01 la famille
qui est très très forte là dessus et
bien quelques jours avant la compétition
je me suis dit tiens pourquoi pas
essayer le taekwondo au sein du TKD 78
et bah je suis en un seul morceau comme
je l'ai dit et plutôt content d'avoir
essayé ce sport image de Patrick Jacques
de Dixmude
chose promise chose due voilà c'est le
premier test pour vous de cette saison
2012-2013 je suis peut-être un peu fou
mais je m'aventure sur le terrain du
Taekwondo Éric Naudin le président du
TKD 78 m'a prêté un très beau kimono que
j'enfile pour la première fois de ma vie
les arts martiaux c'est pas c'est pas
mon credo mais on va essayer il m'a
donné une belle ceinture blanche de
Junior ça devrait ça devrait le faire on
va essayer de se frotter au Taekwondo
dans quelques minutes sans se faire trop
mal on va voir ce que ça donne
salut Alphonse bon je viens pour le test
pour vous bon je suis un petit peu en
retard j'espère que ça mais je suis
motivé pour cette session taekwondo
d'accord je mettrai je vais me
concentrer jusqu'au bout on va y aller
d'accord au milieu
voilà et tu mets le poids de corps
légèrement chargeur
et ici tu viens sous la poitrine inverse
d'accord d'accord
à gauche en bas
donc là faut juste que je fasse
la jambe droite
là je suis perdu pour la première fois
du courant n'est-ce pas
ok c'est bon
il arrive donc il y a une question de
distance de réactivité et de timing
d'accord si tu pars trop tard tu prends
tu pars trop tôt tu le rap d'accord et
si t'es pas la bonne distance
ça commence à devenir dur
de plusieurs c'est de tout synchroniser
entre le fait de faire un kata de faire
des gestes normaux et après de se mettre
en situation de combat c'est ça qui est
le plus difficile la concrétisation du
de l'exercice théorique
je pense que je peux je peux essayer je
l'ai fait à l'échauffement ça devrait
aller
voilà comme on peut le voir ça c'est le
grand écart exercice de l'échauffement
taekwondo pour étirer toutes les
articulations pour qu'elles soient bien
chaude pendant l'entraînement bon je
suis pas encore un pro je suis pas
encore assez à plat pour pouvoir faire
ce que fait mon collègue d'à côté
j'espère pouvoir le faire d'ici quelques
entraînements si je suis à
bon Eric merci pour cet entraînement
cette découverte du Taekwondo heureux
que tu sois venu c'était un grand
plaisir et merci Gabriel mon partenaire
du soir que j'ai un petit peu martyrisé
parce que j'ai pas tout payé toutes les
techniques encore en main bah il est
comme toi il y a pour apprendre et alors
j'ai une question est-ce que j'ai ma
ceinture noire ce soir ou pas non je
crois qu'il va vraiment faire bien de
bosser un peu plus souvent parce que il
y a encore de la matière à bosser là non
non c'est bon c'est léger bon je vais
persévérer alors en tout cas merci 78 et
merci à toi pour pour ce super tester
pour vous et puis le prochain test pour
vous Wilfried vous venez avec moi
oui d'accord et je vais m'entraîner pour
le grand écart vous faites ça tellement
bien Anthony ça reste pour voir ça en
vrai je vais venir avec vous tout à fait
on fera ça la prochaine fois ensemble